about how [ __ ] H&M did the [ __ ]
III can't believe it's a suite is it a
Swedish based company somewhere like
that you know and with only white people
and they came out with that [ __ ]
hoodie that says coolest monkey in the
jungle and they had a black kid model it
on their catalog
dude what by the way the kid this is
maybe weird that kid is the most
handsome kid I've ever seen in my life
dude I mean the kid is like six or
something and he's [ __ ] like smoke in
the camera dude it looks like he's
thinking what's up [ __ ] but how about
Swedish people and then they give an
apology I was like we regret doing it
we're sorry so Swedish to just be like
that sorry how we doing we didn't mean
to we put a kid in there we just thought
that kid was cute we had no idea about
the racial tension and all that anyway
we're gonna make some other hoodies and
it will be fine there are no guns here
nobody kills each other so we don't
really know what it's like over there
but um we're sorry anyway we're gonna
eat some food and make some more hoodies
and call it a day so we started with if
we hurt anybody I'm going to go have sex
with the most beautiful women and it's a
beautiful snowy town and we never had a
war here so we'll catch you later sorry
for hurting a family or two
bye and then [ __ ] Boogie Nights
you know man we just came to a party
ah drinking the champagne what are you
celebrating being Swedish yeah I mean
how do you expect them to [ __ ] know
you know I mean how much would they be
like what'd he look like
how much would they be like well he
looks like that [ __ ] you guys don't know
what's going on anyway your your sit
your America is in [ __ ] trouble
anyway turtle music louder ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding
Lena Lena Lena
[Music]
I love this one don't you remember
hey did you want to shock me off yeah
dinner man no no honey if you eat me out
afterwards no name it'll can be
reciprocal [ __ ] ants Archaean I love
being in Sweden what was what was I
dealing with again an hour ago I forget
[Applause]
play the song again we're still
celebrating celebrating what being
Swedish ah ding ding ding ding ding ding
that thing they're gonna hem ding ding
ding let's play xbox one
we're being Swedish I can tell what
black people look like like just so
don't give a [ __ ] you know I care about
black people look like hey who wants to
make me [ __ ] this time I'm eating turkey
and [ __ ] getting sock it's so
beautiful outside snowing we probably
all have bad breath
how Swedish is it - probably a bad
breath no I actually [ __ ] disagree
with that
I bet [ __ ] Swedish people some I know
probably their armpits some of them
smell bad because they're like [ __ ]
deodorant this is great our life is
amazing [ __ ] this deodorant but hum but
I bet therefore I bet some Swedish
people smell so goddamn good it's like
[ __ ] candy and you need to have your
face in their face male or female not in
a gay way but you want to be like yo bro
let me breathe your breath
you know I guarantee there's some
Swedish I guarantee the best smelling
[ __ ] breath is Swedish and
you're like yo bro let me smell your
[ __ ] breath get your [ __ ] face
close to mine
breathing me [ __ ] say something
so I can [ __ ] smell your breath and
he's like I can't help what black people
look like and you smell it and you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah you're racist and you
don't know it but you kind of not raise
this cuz you just sayin [ __ ] it's weird
you guys are perfect you got the best
lives this is heaven yeah I think you're
right
Sweden is better than heaven everyone
seems to be getting along
I think Tupac would like me here